من رالي إلى دنفر وبيفرلي هيلز ، أدت
هذه الانتخابات الرئاسية إلى تصعيد
التوترات ، لذا فإن
المدن المرتفعة تضع الاستعدادات للإعصار
مثل الإجراءات في مكانها للتصدي
للاضطرابات المحتملة بعد الانتخابات
تنضم إلينا CNN's brent grass الآن
خارج
المتجر الرئيسي الشهير لمايسي في مدينة نيويورك
التي كانت على متنها  حتى الجمعة ، ما
الذي يمكن أن تخبرنا به أكثر عن هذا
المطعم الرائع بلومينغديلز في
مدينة نيويورك ، وهو نوع من
قسم التسوق الفاخر في سوهو جميعًا
،
وهذا شيء لا يقتصر تطبيق القانون عليه
هنا فقط ولكن كما ذكرت في
جميع أنحاء
البلاد.  لم نشهد قبل الانتخابات ،
هذا أمر غير
مسبوق بشكل خطير وما نتعلمه بشكل
أساسي هو
أن جميع هذه الشركات تتخذ احتياطات غير متأكدة
مما يمكن توقعه ليس فقط في يوم الانتخابات
ولكن بالطبع بعد
تطبيق القانون يفعل نفس المخاوف
لما سمعته للتو  سوزان
سوزان الحديث عن تخويف الناخبين
الاضطرابات المحتملة
بعد الانتخابات على نطاق واسع بروتين  تحدث
الجماعات المتطرفة عن
حوادث الإرهاب المحلي المحتملة التي شهدناها
بشكل خاص خلال الصيف ، لقد مرت
عقودًا من الزمان بصراحة تامة منذ أن رأينا
المتاجر حتى تبدأ في البداية ،
ونحن نعلم الآن أن تطبيق القانون يستمع إلى
أنهم يعملون معًا.  لقد تحدثنا إلى
مصادر تقول على
وجه الخصوص هنا في نيويورك أنه
لا يوجد مصدر قلق كبير بشأن الاضطرابات الرئيسية ولكن
هناك أيضًا تنسيق في الولايات المتشددة وبالطبع هناك تنسيق على المستوى
المحلي ومستوى الدولة الفيدرالية في جميع
أنحاء هذا البلد لأي
شيء قد يأتي ليس فقط  في يوم الانتخابات
ولكن بالطبع في الأيام التي تلي ذلك ،
والتحدث إلى الناس هنا في نيويورك على
الأقل يمكنني أن أخبرك
أنهم يقولون إن هناك القليل من
القلق في الهواء كما تعلم أن أحدهم
أخبرنا أنها لا تتوقع تركها
شقة في يوم الانتخابات في الأيام
التي تليها فقط خوفًا مما قد يكون في
شوارع المدينة
في تلك الأيام ، لذلك هناك بالتأكيد
قلق ولكن الآن الأمر كله يتعلق
بالعلاقات العامة  انفصال ليومين
وربما أسابيع قادمة